- True or false and why:
You don't brush your hair.
[Laughing]
- That is false.
I do brush my hair.
What do you mean?
[Crowd cheering]
I don't believe I can do
anything in this life by myself.
- [Announcer:] Lob it in once
again, Durant single coverage.
Shoots over hard
and knocks it down.
- Do you write music?
- I write rhymes sometimes,
in the studio with just about -
Not everybody,
but with a lot of people.
- OK, where's the song?
♪♪
- Yo, this is KD
I'm about to "Take it There"
with Taylor Rooks.
I know she got a lot,
a lot of deep questions
she want to ask me.
I'm looking forward to it.
[Crowd cheering]
- Kevin Durant!
[Horns honking]
- [Taylor Rooks:] Thank you
for letting me spend
your New York off-day with you.
- No doubt.
- Is living in the city
everything you thought
it was going to be?
- Yeah, it is.
You always hear
the bad things about the city,
and not so much the great
things that can happen.
Every day I feel like I take
a piece of New York City,
in a way, to work with me.
- Yeah.
- So it's pretty cool.
- Well, I know you love Jue Lan.
This is one of your favorites.
- Yes. Yes.
And you love all the food here.
You love Dara.
Now I know...
- My guy. Appreciate it, bro.
- ...you're here so much
that Dara actually knows
your order -
Memorized.
- Yes.
- What does he get?
- Kev loves the chicken satay
and the shrimp satay.
Those are his go-tos.
- With the fried rice.
- [Dara:] That's right -
fried rice.
Man, we go back almost,
what, 10 years now,
coming back and forth
to New York City, you know.
- [Taylor Rooks:] Mmhmm.
- So I've got
friends here already.
And I live right around
the corner. It was easy, man.
- I met you when you were
an All-Star in Orlando,
playing for the Thunder.
We've been friends since then.
What's the biggest difference
between the Kevin I met then,
and the Kevin you are now?
- [Kevin Durant:]
Just a natural evolution
of being more comfortable
with myself.
And I just removed
a lot of distractions
that I was putting on myself,
I guess.
- [Taylor:] What was the hardest
distraction to remove?
- [Kevin:] Worrying about how
I'd be viewed after a game
or how I'd feel after a loss
instead of just focusing on
getting better
as a player every day.
I stopped investing too much
in, like,
just the outcome of the games
and more so just kept it
at the work that I put in.
- I don't understand this.
Why on Earth
did every person think
you were going to the Knicks?
- It's the NBA.
Anything can start.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Any rumors happening,
and stuff starts.
It's just the nature
of the beast.
- There was KD/
Knicks billboards.
It was, like,
already graphics of KD
and Kyrie and Zion,
like, in Knicks uniforms.
- Every fan on social media
enjoys seeing
what their team is doing
as far as free agency.
- I was at the Nets game
against the Suns.
You were pump faking.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Fake dribbling,
fake shooting.
And I was like, "I know Kevin.
He is itching to come back
right now."
- Yeah.
The culture of the game is, uh,
definitely missing
from my life right now.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Kevin:] The team aspect of,
you know,
watching film every day
and just having
a goal to meet.
As a basketball player,
I definitely miss that.
So any chance I get
to be on the floor...
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- ...and kind of do
my shadow moves -
I just try to envision what
it'll be like when I get back.
- Are you itching?
Like, are you ready?
- [Kevin:] Most definitely.
My body's going to get there
eventually,
but mentally, you know, I would
love to play again, for sure.
- So is there any chance we see
you come back this season?
- No, I don't think so.
Not for right now.
- You don't think so or no?
- No.
- Cuz those are
two different answers.
- No, no.
The best thing for me
is to continue to rehab,
get as strong as I can,
and focus on next season.
- OK, I want you to really
paint this picture for me.
You've been asked
a couple times,
but you haven't
really elaborated.
- [Kevin:] Yeah.
- When you're back,
what is this Nets team
going to look like?
- I have no clue. I mean -
- You -
I know you think about it.
- I do.
- You're a hoop head.
All you think about
all the time is basketball.
- Yeah.
- [Taylor:] So tell me,
when you're thinking
about the Nets squad,
like, what's in your head?
- [Kevin:] Just different
lineups that we can play and use
and with guys that work well
with each other's skills,
putting on the jersey,
and actually representing
Brooklyn on the road.
That's going to be
an exciting time, as well.
- I think that this has become
such a big part of your story.
It's discussed so much.
Your time with the Warriors.
Maybe the way
Golden State views you.
It came up again recently
with Ja Morant and Steph Curry.
Ja Morant said something
about Iggy.
Steph posted a photo of Iggy
with his trophy.
Ja Morant posts a photo of you
with your trophy.
What do you feel like
Ja Morant was implying
by posting that photo?
- I don't know.
I mean, there's always
been speculation
about what my place
was on the team
and what I meant to the team.
And I don't think they got
anybody on the Warriors,
like, upset that he posted
a picture of me.
We all brothers, and we won
championships together.
It wasn't anything more than
I guess just a little jab,
I guess.
- I think that the narrative,
though,
that was on social media,
separate from the Warriors,
was like, they got those two
cuz KD was there.
- It's narratives. They got
narratives for everything.
There's a lot of stuff
the casual fan
don't get about the game.
So they make a lot of
speculation on what they see,
and it's not
the whole picture.
- The one thing you do say
when this happens,
you're like, "We're talking
about basketball, not life."
Like, nobody
is not friends after.
- Yeah, it's not -
Yeah, I mean, cuz you hear
all the trash talk in games.
But it's like, we're all
a family at the end of the day,
but we still compete hard
against each other,
but we still want
to protect each other
when we're off the floor,
and we all respect what we do.
- I think the talk when
you were deciding
what team you're going to go to
after Golden State was, like,
do you feel like you have to
win a ring somewhere else
to solidify this idea that you
can just win a championship.
- I don't believe I can do
anything in this life by myself.
I never felt that we can
win championships
based off of only
what I do.
I felt that way in OKC
when we had success
and Golden State
when we had success.
And it's going to have to be
the same thing in Brooklyn.
A lot of people seen
that I left
a successful organization
and wonder why.
For the most part, it's just
wanting to just make a change
in my career.
It was simple as that.
- It's so crazy to think what
OKC could have been, though.
- Everybody says that, man.
- It really is.
- Sometimes the business
gets in the way,
and sometimes things
just don't happen.
But that run we did have
was special.
- It absolutely was.
- Going to the Finals.
I ain't going to
never forget that.
[Laughing]
- It's interesting to hear you
talk about other teams
you've been on
because you clearly have
these incredibly fond memories
about the teams.
- [Kevin:] Yeah.
But the way it's painted
is that that isn't it.
- Yeah. I mean, I'm just so open
and honest about the experience.
I want the message to always be
without those experiences,
I wouldn't be close
to who I am today.
And they all made me,
and still embedded in my DNA -
OKC and Golden State.
And hopefully I can take this
into my next experience
and be even better.
- I think, like,
a lot of players,
and really a lot of people,
say, you know,
"I don't care
what people think."
But I don't think
most people mean it.
- No.
- Do you mean it?
- Yeah. I mean, I feel like I'm
passionate about my art.
I've heard Erykah Badu
say that.
And I was. I feel that.
- OK, so I play this segment
with a lot of people
that come on the show,
and it's called
"True or False and Why?"
- [Kevin:] Mmhmm.
- The best NBA players
come from the DMV.
- Oh, my God.
- [Laughing]
- True.
- OK. Why?
- I look at regions that when it
comes to basketball players,
is guys that fill
a specific role,
and I feel like the DMV is made
for guys that get buckets.
- What other cities, like,
do you put in there?
I know it's a compilation
of cities, but -
- Um, you can put Chicago
in there.
You know, a lot of guys
from Chicago,
their staple is defense,
but they got some good
one-on-one players
and good bucket-getters
out there in Chicago.
- I think LA is more so
guys that can do everything -
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- from pass
to score to athleticism.
Just seeing so many influences
out on that side of the country
as well can definitely help
a young kid form
who he wants to be
on the floor.
So I look at all that stuff when
it comes to looking at players
and what got me
to this point as well.
- [Taylor:]
True or false and why:
You want to be a music
producer when you retire.
- [Chuckling] False.
- [Laughing] OK.
- I did a few years back,
not realizing how tough it is
to actually become
great at that.
Right now I just got
so much respect
for a lot of guys
in that position to say:
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
-"I'm just going to do this
when I'm done," you know?
So.
- Yeah, like,
it's harder than that.
- Yeah, it's way harder
than that.
- OK. True or false and why:
people take you too seriously.
- Um, true.
The main topic around me
the last few years
is moving teams,
and that hit
a lot of people hard.
So now whenever I say something,
it's getting blown
out of proportion.
Sometimes I'm like,
"You can just ignore me."
That's what my whole thing is.
You can just ignore me,
but I understand
where it comes from.
- True or false and why:
You don't brush your hair.
[Laughing]
- That is false.
I do brush my hair.
What do you mean?
- [Taylor:] Well, people
always talk about that.
- Yeah, on the basketball court,
I don't care.
I come to the games, actually,
just roll out of bed
and just go play.
I mean, I'm on TV a lot
when I do these things,
so I see why people make that...
[Laughing]
But my whole thought process
is like,
I'm really just rolling
out of bed to go hoop
and come right back home.
- Some of the memes are funny.
- Of course, it is.
-Yeah.
-It's funny, yeah.
I got to laugh at it
if I'm going to laugh
at all that other stuff
they put on there.
- Obviously before you got hurt,
there was this, what,
like, this three-
to four-year stretch
where you could
absolutely argue
you were the best player
on the planet.
- [Kevin:]
If you want to argue that.
- Do you think
it could be argued?
- Yeah. It could be argued
for a lot of guys.
But, yeah, I feel like
I was in that argument.
If you want to break
into that conversation,
you got to do some
great shit in the league.
You know, you got to really go
out there and leave your mark
and leave your stamp
on the game.
And I want to be
in those conversations.
I want to play
for a long time -
to have longevity in the game
or playing in the league.
That's because of what the guys
before me had laid out,
from the Jordans
to the Kobes to KGs
to the Tim Duncans
to the LeBrons.
Even now, I'm still getting
pushed by players
in the league now,
from the James Hardens
to the Stephs to Giannis -
guys that are going
to be legends
and Hall of Famers
when they're done.
It's pretty cool to know
that I've played
with some of the greatest
players of all time,
and they respect my game.
- Now, unquestionable greatness,
the greatest - Kobe Bryant.
How did losing Kobe Bryant
affect you?
- Just can't stop
thinking about it, man.
Kobe is somebody
that I competed against
and was a teammate of
as well.
I can go on and on about
how he made me feel
as a person and as a player,
and I just - I love him.
I'm always - it's always
going to be in my heart.
Always going to think about him
when I go out there
and play and perfect my craft,
and just try to do right by him
by being the best person
and player I can be every day.
You know, being on a team
with somebody
and being their teammate,
you really see them
for who they,
who they really are to the core.
It's hard for me
even to think about,
you know, cuz, like, man,
I wish he was still around.
- You said there were
little moments with Kobe
that impacted you.
What are some of those?
- [Kevin:] Just the first few
practices as Team USA in 2012,
just his approach to practice,
and then also how he played
in the games and his focus
and what he wanted
to do out there on the court.
He was a defender for us
and a shot-maker.
So, like, to see Kobe
play a role
outside of just being
the main scorer,
it showed me that anybody can,
you know, lock into a role
and perfect it.
So it made me respect him
even more
for just being a well-rounded,
well-versed player.
As a hooper, I wanted
his aesthetic as a player.
It was pretty sweet
to see his methods,
and I didn't really get
to appreciate it
until I got older
as a player
and started to see,
"Oh, that's what he meant
when he was doing it this way.
Oh, that's how he felt
when he played in this game."
So I'm always going to live
with Kobe in my heart.
- Bryant attacking.
All the way. Dunks it home!
Kobe down the middle
with authority!
[Crowd cheering]
- [Taylor:] Question for you:
What player from the '90s
would you most like to see
in the modern NBA?
- Shaq, for sure.
He'd be the most interesting
to see right now.
- [Taylor:] OK. Why?
- [Kevin:] Cuz he's so big
and agile and athletic
that he can run
and play in a pace
and space that we do now,
but you couldn't play
small guys against him,
so it'd be - he'd be the
ultimate, like,
cheat code for the game.
- OK, so what's your drink
of choice?
- I got a little 1942 in here.
- No - not on the rocks?
Just '42 straight with a lime?
- Straight. Yup.
- OK.
All right,
let's talk some music.
I know that's another one
of your passion points.
What five songs are
in your rotation right now?
- Can I check my phone?
- Of course.
- What I'm listening
to the most right now?
- Mmhmm.
- "War" by Drake.
- [Taylor, laughing:]
You love that song.
- Every day - I listen to it
at least three times a day.
Uh, "Guess What," Russ,
Rick Ross.
That's a dope song. You got to
check Russ' album out.
Fivio Foreign - Brooklyn,
so I got to represent that.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- And 2 Chainz,
"Virgil Discount."
And I go "JackBoys,"
"Gang Gang."
- Sheck Wes...
- Yeah.
- ...Don Toliver.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- Uh, Travis.
I'm really starting
to follow producers now.
- OOh, who are some of your
favorites?
- Boi-1da, 40 -
Those two guys are
probably the -
got me into, like,
wanting to follow producers.
Um, especially, you know, one of
my favorite artists in Drake -
they produce a lot of his stuff.
Um, then into some new cats
that I heard -
AXL Beats, uh, Rico Beats -
There's a lot of guys
that I follow on Instagram
that they post little snippets
of their music that I enjoy.
♪♪
- Do you write music?
- Uh, I write rhymes sometimes.
- OK.
- I got a little scrapbook
full of raps, I guess, yeah.
- Do you ever record it?
- Yeah, I do.
- Really?
- Yeah. I mean, it's fun
to get off
and get in the studio, yeah.
That's a huge hobby.
It's underrated how many guys
have their own in-home studios
as basketball players.
I go to some big studios
sometimes,
but most of the time I'm just
in the house creating stuff
and having people come over.
Me and JaVale McGee -
he's huge.
Like, he has -
produces his own tapes.
He has huge artists
on his mix tape, as well.
I feel like every team I've been
on had at least one or two guys
that didn't mind
getting into the studio.
So, yeah, it's pretty fun.
- I had DeMar DeRozan
on the show last season,
and he said he has a whole
mix tape...
- Yes.
- ...no one's heard except for
Kyle Lowry, Drake,
and Kendrick Lamar.
- When we was in, I want to say
2014 or -
one of those, me and DeMar
got in the studio in Vegas.
- [Taylor:] No!
- Me, DeMar,
and Rudy - Rudy Gay.
- [Taylor:] Rudy Gay raps?
- Yeah.
You know, we all just
play around in there.
- OK, where's the song?
Like, where - where's it at?
- Nobody's going to
put no records out.
We just doing it for fun.
- I'mma find those songs.
Trust.
- No, you're not going
to find them.
- I'mma find them.
-Nah uh.
- I don't know where or how,
but you know I want mine.
OK, so you have a song
with DeMar and Rudy.
I think you and LeBron
have a song.
- Yeah.
- Who else?
- Uh, you heard me
and Stephen Jackson had one.
A couple cats that
I knew playing ball.
Myck Kabongo who played -
who was an undrafted player
coming into the league
a few years back.
I mean, I got songs in
the studio with just about -
not everybody,
but with a lot of people.
- OK, if you had a rap name,
what would it be?
- [Laughing]
Probably "Easy Money."
- OK.
"Easy Money" -
you can rhyme with that.
- "Easy Money" or 'Slim Reaper."
One of those probably.
Pick between those two -
or both.
- OK, another top-five
question.
- Yeah.
- You could only watch
basketball highlights
of five players forever.
- I like that.
- Who are the players?
- Kobe, Mike.
Damn, that's tough.
That's tough.
I watch film.
Shaq, Magic, Bron.
- OK.
- If I couldn't watch
nobody else,
and they said I just had
to watch those five,
I think I could be good
the rest of my life.
- [Taylor:] My favorite game
that I play on the show.
It is called "On This Day,
You Posted."
- Oh, damn.
- OK?
- I got a lot of posts.
- Yes, you do.
[Laughing]
May, 2010,
"Twitter is better
than goin' to da club."
- I was having a wack night
in the club that night.
Nobody was dancing. Everybody
was just staring at each other,
and I was like,
"This is what I come here for?"
I guess I had an epiphany.
When I have an epiphany
in my mind,
sometimes I say it,
and that was one of those times.
- Is Twitter still better
than going to the club?
- Some nights.
[Taylor laughing]
- August, 2009:
- Damn.
- "I remember
when I got attacked by a dog
walking to the bus stop.
I got on the bus, and I
didn't have no lunch money.
I got robbed by a dog."
- [Laughing]
- Yeah, I remember that.
- Please tell this story.
- I was kindergarten, walking to
the bus by myself,
and a dog came out
of nowhere.
Ruff, ruff, ruff, ruff.
I'm reaching in my pocket
when I got on the bus.
"Damn, I can't eat today.
It must have fell out
of my pocket."
And I was like,
"I got robbed by a dog."
- The dog. Dog thief.
- The dog got me.
- Last but not least,
my personal favorite.
July 2011:
"Bubble guts
woke me up out my sleep."
- I remember that.
- "I had to check my sheets
for any slippage."
- Ahh, that's embarrassing.
But I was really a comedian
at that point on Twitter.
Or trying to be.
And I thought it was funny.
- You didn't have
no bubble guts?
- Of co-
If you have bubble guts in your
life, I mean, come on now.
- The real question is:
Did you have any slippage?
- No. Mnh-mnh.
Nah. Uh uh.
Yo, can we cut that?
This don't need to be on...
No, we don't need
to take it there.
- With Taylor Rooks?
- Yeah, of course.
- [Laughing]
- Of course. Shameless plug.
- All right, KD, thank you so
much for coming on to the show.
- No doubt.
- We got to cheers to that.
- Yes. To my fans.
♪♪